ما الذي سنتتابعه في هذه الليله الطويله
سنتابع نتائج انتخابات جميع ااا مجلس
النواب البالغ عددها
435 مقعدا يتارجح اكثر من 30 منها بين
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي والتي ستبدا
بالظهور من ولايتي كنتاكي وانديانا بعد
حوالي اقل ساعه من الان لاحظوا معي قبل
هذه الانتخابات ان تنطلق الحزب الديمقراطي
كان يسيطر على مجلس النواب بمئتين 220
مقعدا مقابل 200 واثني عشر للحزب الجمهوري
هل هذا سيستمر كل المؤشرات واستطاعات
الراي تقول بان لا هذا السيناريو سيتغير
لان استطلاعات الراي تعطي تقدما ملحوظا
للحزب الجمهوري في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
اذا كما اسلفت الانتخابات على جميع
الولايات وكل المقاعد التي هي مخصصه
مجلس النواب في الكونجرس الامريكي ماذا
سنتابع ايضا سنتابع المنافسه على 35 مقعدا
من مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ وعددها 100 مقعد في
سباق يسعى فيه الديمقراطيون للحفاظ على
اغلبيتهم لاحظوا معي الديمقراطيون هم
حاصلون على 36 مقعدا في مجلس الشيوخ مقابل
29 للحزب الجمهوري هذه المقاعد هي خارج
المنافسه المنافسه كما اسلفت على 35 مقعدا
في هذه الانتخابات على مجلس الشيوخ التي
هي مهمه جدا وايضا استطلاعات الراي همم
تعطي افضليه طفيفه للحزب الجمهوري تلاحظ
معي هنا الحزب الديمقراطي حاصل على 34
مقعد او ينطلق من 34 مقعد في هذه
الانتخابات طبعا تلاحظون باللون الازرق
الغامق هم للحزب الديمقراطي بينما باللون
الازرق الفاتحه
سيناتور مستقلات ولكن معروف بانهم يساوي
تان لصالح
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ مقابل 29
للحزب الجمهوري هذه الولايات ال- الاصفر
هي الولايات التي تشهد منافسه وايضا تشهد
سباق على مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ فيها ولايات
مهمه يجب ان نتوقف عندها هذه الولايات
المهمه منها على سبيل المثال ولايه جورجيا
هي مهمه جدا وتعتبر متارجحه وحاسمه ولايه
تنسل فين يا ايضا مهمه جدا ستتابعوا معنا
هذه الولايه التي تعبت تعتبر ايضا مهمه
وقد تقلب وتغير موازين القوى بين الحزبين
ايضا هناك همم نيفادا اريزونا وسكنسون وان
يهنشر هذه الولايات التي صنفت بانها
ولايات متارجحه وستكون حاسمه ايضا في هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه سنتابع ايضا
كفس على 36 منصبا من مناصب حكام الولايات
الخمسين وهنا نراها هذه الولايات التي
ستشهد انتخابات على صعيد حكام الولايات
ظاهره معنا باللون الاصفر اذا